okay so what age my age-old partners
like yeah what age could he be he needs
well I don't date too high up so I'm 30
so he needs to be 30 to 30 till 33.
uh 30 to 33. okay do you care about race
okay I won't go 35 but yeah we put him
30 to 35 then okay but 29 to 34.
okay uh can you make the Box slightly
bigger I just I'm having a hard time
reading it or can you zoom in on the
page
yeah there we go yes yes thank you okay
you can still see that okay make it a
little bigger no it's fine I have good
eyesight I just need to book an
appointment aspect
yeah so uh race do you care about race
um sorry yeah I do care about racism
yeah black okay now how no Prejudice to
the other races but I'm I'm comfortable
with black first all right everyone has
a type no I'm not Shane shading anyone
um minimum height oh I didn't used to
care about height but my boyfriend he's
actually six four and I think that's
like really cute
um as long as they're not shorter than
me no five seven to six five seven to
six six four six and then minimum income
do you want to obese guys
can he be can he be overweight
um what's overweight
obese like how much it's like 30
something percent body fat do you mean
like he can't fit through the door obese
or like I'm it's fine I don't health is
something that can change okay so that's
okay minimum income
minimum three grand
so let me put that I'm gonna do the
conversion for you because I don't
actually but you know yeah you want tax
on top of that he's gonna be earning
like 70 grand a year at least okay
it could be after tax I don't mind okay
so how how much so three grand that's
your final answer yes
a thousand
and Hounds this isn't it uh
3700 US dollars so that's times twelve
that's forty four thousand that's not
bad um US dollars
okay wait now so what percent of men do
you think fit that criteria before we do
it
um at least
at least 30 percent okay wow
the age of the races
three percent did we do America
it's similar it's similar wow so three
percent three percent yeah go go ahead
your turn
go ahead your turn wow put it put in
your criteria
oh yeah your turn oh no okay it's okay
you know eight I'd say 25 to 30.
okay uh race
um
guys if you didn't hear um King forgot
to exclude married people so it's
probably 1.5 percent
um okay racy did you say I'm gonna go
for any race anyways okay
minimum height
um five seven
obese no exclude obese minimum income
no discrimination by Me by the way it's
just my preference people
um I think it's okay to discriminate who
you should be discriminating you should
discriminate and who you date because I
want people to discriminate on me but
anyway
so minimum income I think she should be
picky with who you sleep with come on
that's true
um minimum after tax I'd say take home
at least 2.5 okay
that is
three thousand one
130 I can't do math so I need to
calculate it times 12. okay that's 37
000. okay that's off the tax I'm gonna
go for
in the this is the yeah but okay 40 is
fine
all right what do you think what do you
think I'm gonna go for 15 15 okay go
down
[Laughter]
just get like higher so
um I want to go like
38. no actually I want to go 40 if
there's only can you do five years or
can you do more than five years
like 38 to 48.
what about married man you're gonna go
for a married man take them off take off
those married men
not worried about the race minimum
height five eleven oh
I feel you minimum income it's got to be
over 100 a year
by the time you're there right so 100K
in
pounds yeah okay so that's a hundred and
roughly put 120 US Dollars that's
roughly what percent of men
I'm hoping when they get to the age
we're looking like early 20s
21 22 22 a man yeah
graph no chance
wow 0.49 wow my pool is small like one
percent of them one percent of people in
the UK are earning and over 100. oh my
god wow and that's all Races that's
girls you better choose now
um go ahead oh okay um let's do like 18
to that 23.
and I'm no married man
I should have said that
Oh Black
um
six foot
um um
oh no no these people
respectfully
um
let's do like TK per month
so that's yeah
um 2K is roughly
two like three we'll do Americans no I
need to calculate it
uh that's two five American so that's
times twelve that's thirty thousand
um
um what percent of men do you guys think
that is I would like 10 no not two you
think low oil
oh my God it's just like one no wow how
much money do you think young men
more than that what do you think like 2K
is a lot for someone yeah that's when
you go into like uni and stuff like that
yeah you're figuring things out
but like we're flagged someone who's
like just going straight into work and
is like working full time
yeah they won't get that this is why men
are struggling
I used to do Recruitment and I I haven't
gone to UNI and I used to recruit people
that had just come out of uni and they
were you're going on like 23 some
companies might give you 26 like max if
you're just coming but you can obviously
make commission on that but again that's
a good six nine months if you're putting
in that hard work like hours yeah did we
do the whole couch everyone's gone on
the couch yeah
money
okay do your do your oh but I didn't I
don't I think money is vulgar so don't
ask about it I don't talk about money
but like I just will assume based on
like what we're doing and like where
you're taking me yeah you have money
yeah I like I have no idea how much my
boyfriend earns he just owns a business
and he handles his own finances so good
job you got him in the chart
okay so how how old
when you were on the market
oh that's a really hard question to be
honest because I have dated old I have
gone old before but like I'm not judging
you but now I'm trying to have babies so
I've gone like younger what is that
counter I would think that's
counterintuitive so before I was saying
a guy like who was like middle-aged and
he'd like already had his kids and stuff
oh here it is so now I'm dating a guy
like in his mid-30s because he's you
know
um so like I don't know it depends if
I'm dating for like marriage so how old
are you again I'm 25. okay so 20 would
you go no I wouldn't go younger than
myself okay so 25 is the minimum 40.
yeah okay
I'm 26 so that's roughly mine too
um okay any race oh yeah anyways
I I'm not I don't really have any height
restrictions
I think yeah
so five foot yeah I I don't I think if I
fell in love with them it wouldn't
bother me
so five foot you're good yeah okay put
her five foot I don't think that many
percentage of people are five have you
ever have you ever dated a guy shorter
than you yeah I've dated someone five
six before uh wait no I'm five for five
I've dated somebody like my height okay
but not shorter but I don't meet many
men shorter than me because yeah I'm
just not a type woman so like I'm cool
of men it's smaller minimum income
I don't know
[Music]
um
like I just I I just you know I've never
really talked about money I don't look
at the bill when it comes like my
boyfriend pays for things but like I
just don't like but then also when I was
younger like I when I was 19 like my
boyfriend paid for everything and he was
18 and like he didn't have any money
yeah paid for everything he just took me
to things within his means do you know
what I mean yeah so if money's I'm just
asking a rough estimate so you're
looking to marry a guy like
30k or if I want to have his babies like
I want him to be able to support my
children I guess I could compat my
salary so that's like roughly 40 US
roughly yeah yeah
what percent I'm gonna guess like 20.
wow I'm gonna guess 20. it also depends
on your circle though because I don't
know any men that earn less than that
go down down oh 12. I was wrong does
this surprise you guys
does it surprise you no
women always come up with these crazy
numbers for men oh they're going 100
Grand no they don't yeah to be able to
earn a liver you don't need to be added
as much as you as you think
um even to be able to support support a
family I know times are getting harder
because of the cost of living but um
yeah I think it's just world and this is
why red has struggling societal pressure
lack of communication is the main main
reason why men are deleting themselves
um it's such a huge problem it's a bit
of an unspoken concern because of this
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible